okay so we are finally getting back into
the abyss storyline from joshua
williamson's batman because it just
finished right in the first video that
we did we basically cover this idea of
like the return of batman incorporated
for those of you guys who don't know
what that meant the the long story being
short is basically batman took like the
batman concept worldwide um and just set
up like different batman teams in
different parts of the world some of
which were rolled over into the main
family in gotham city others just kind
of continued on out there it was really
just based on the popularity of the
character when dc introduced those
individuals uh but essentially what had
happened is that something had gone on
where batman incorporated right these
people out there uh where they had
essentially killed a guy by the name of
abyss and so the result of this is that
batman is currently investigating it
only to find out that because he had
basically lost his fortune due to the
events of the joker war and joker and
basically punchline essentially taking
all his money that batman incorporated
had basically lost their funding as well
only to turn around and find themselves
funded by lex luthor and so that's what
we are here at the moment where
basically batman and lex luthor are
essentially meeting and we're sort of
learning what's going on behind the
scenes that lex luthor was finding
batman incorporated and so that's kind
of the funny thing is that lex luthor
really seems to be pretty legal here
right in the sense that he's like i'm
cooperating with law enforcement i fully
support them and this city right like
i'm i'm basically a legit guy now this
is done from the perspective in that
following his experiences where he had
basically been like a version of
superman albeit one that was
technologically based uh where he had
actually been darkseid at one point in
time that if you guys recall the events
of like forever evil when essentially
the crime syndicate invaded the earth
and that all the superheroes were
essentially captured and lex luthor had
to basically bring together villains in
order to turn them into heroes in order
to basically save the world and the
heroes themselves uh that he's had a lot
of lessons over the course of this time
and one of those lessons is that he
essentially has turned over a new leaf
right he's basically gone legit but in
the middle of this meeting of course you
end up having the cops who show up they
realize it's a batman and they just
opened fire right it's really just kind
of like this this kill-on-side order now
of course bruce wayne basically throws
down a smoke bomb and essentially
everybody ends up you know basically you
know blind and whatnot and then he
essentially uh preserves the crime scene
and like that's basically it right
everything's kind of sorted and so
following that you basically switch up
with with lex luthor inviting bruce
wayne to dinner now one of the things to
remember is lex luthor knows bruce
wayne's batman and he's known for a very
long time right that's not really a
relatively new thing um but he kind of
tells us a bit of a story about a bottle
of wine and how expensive it is and kind
of pours it out it's not really a
necessary thing uh what is important
here is he says i know you're broke like
i know you lost everything financially
i'm currently funding batman
incorporated let me fund you like in
effect he's giving batman a job offer
right he's like come and work for me
like work for me as batman you'll stay
in gotham city you'll do your thing you
can run it however you want to but i'll
be the finance here right i'll be the
one to financially back you of course it
also pisses them off
[Laughter]
but it's one of these things where bruce
wayne just doesn't trust lex luthor
where like no matter what goes on that
regardless of what kind of perception he
puts on that lex luthor is always
involved in some shady stuff right
there's always something that's just not
right here and so what you end up
getting is basically this body of abyss
that's being examined by batman and at
the same time it's supposed to be in the
morgue now what ends up happening is of
course the body that was left in the
morgue was basically a decoy right like
what happens is it seems like bruce
wayne has his hands on the actual body
of abyss but then suddenly everything
starts going dark batman goes to throw
some flashbangs to try to bring in some
light but essentially everything's just
kind of darkened out and none of his
lights really seen or none of his tools
seem to work right night vision infrared
none of it works but that's when he's
met by the arrival of abyss right he can
see himself he just can't see anything
else around him and so in that moment
that's when he realizes okay so like
abyss is here right he's like abyss is a
guy who's actually alive this body is a
fake body he picked up on that pretty
fast because abyss was killed not too
long ago this body is a person who's
basically been decaying for a couple
months so the timetables just simply
don't add up uh but he's kinda like okay
cool so like you know it's it's it's
kind of one of those dark night rises
kind of things you know like like you
know you adopted the dog you know that
that kind of a thing right where he's
like look i'm batman i fight in the dark
so having darkness here is not gonna do
you any good the thing about this though
is that abyss is he's he's he is he's
not your average bear
this is not just some average guy using
the darkness to his own uh his own tools
instead he kind of taunts him to a
degree when batman asks him like who are
you he's like i'm a creature of the
darkness right born in the shadows just
like you and he's like the voices in the
dark are my only master i don't work for
lex luthor because that's initially
that's the initial response to the
question of bruce wayne is how are you
involved with lex luthor like do you
work for him and so ultimately he
actually ends up managing to overcome
batman and the reason for this is
because he's fast and he's silent he's
almost ninja in nature and it's really
something that batman hasn't seemed to
counter before more so than that it's
not simply an attack on bruce wayne that
what happens is because of the scythe
he's using and the way he's able to
injure bruce wayne he basically blinds
him but he leaves bruce wayne blinded
and that's literally one of the things
right like like this this copies and
working with she comes running up on him
she's like look we gotta get out of here
right the whole building's getting ready
to go on lockdown we have to get out of
here now and he says i can't right
everything is too dark that he has an
effect lost his sight as a result of the
actions or the the the injury that was
done to him by abyss right that abyss
has some kind of tool at his disposal
when it comes to this stuff now the
first thing batman has to do here is
figure out how to reverse this blindness
right it's the first thing he has to do
figure out how to get this blindness
removed and how to essentially regain
his ability to see and he was just like
you know as far as i can tell there's no
real way to do this but i need to get to
a place that's dark i need to get to a
place where i can basically
operate without anybody knowing who i am
or anybody being able to see me and that
even includes the cop herself right so
of course they end up going to her
apartment which is kind of a weird place
abyss also catches up to lex luthor
which is something that happens we don't
really get a whole lot here uh we
basically just get him like powering up
this batman suit which really looks
amazing right like lex luthor
essentially becomes batman which is
pretty legit but the thing about this is
that lex luthor is not on the same level
as bruce wayne when it comes to like
fighting and when it comes to just
tactics and so on so he is seemingly
overcome by uh by abyss pretty fast
right we don't see what happens we just
see the two of them engage in a fight
and that's seemingly it the other thing
here is that ultimately bruce wayne
can't really seem to find a way to heal
his eyesight and so he's ultimately just
kind of stuck there being blind and so
he says okay fine then the next thing we
have to do here is get a hold of batman
incorporated we have to find out why the
body in the morgue was a decoy right
like there's something bigger going on
here and they know what's going on right
like we have to know why they went after
abyss they have all the answers to the
questions that we have and so one of the
things that that uh that this detective
says is like look lex luthor funds all
the prisons right status state of the
art security all that kind of stuff and
the the guy the warden who runs it is in
no doubt trying to make sure that he
stays in lex luthor's good graces so
what's likely going to happen to your
members of batman incorporated is
they're all going to be shuffled off to
solitary confinement right 23 hour
lockdown if not 24 hour lockdown just
kind of you know consistently you're
never going to be able to get to them
the only way to access them is when
they're being transferred and that's
exactly what happens that batman
basically catches up to them as they're
all being transferred to solitary
confinement takes out all the lights and
where they initially think it's abyss
due to the fact that they've encountered
abyss before and this whole scenario
unfolds the same way batman appears and
says no this is my move right and
initially he tells them like get to the
roof like you need to get to the roof
and we need to have a discussion the
response to them is no that's not going
to happen they basically turn against
batman right like he's like look i know
you guys are all innocent i know what's
going on with abyss or at least i seem
to have some idea with abyss i know he's
not dead right that means you all didn't
kill him we need to go talk and where
it's kind of like where they when they
ask him like why are you talking weird
that kind of a thing where he seems a
little off-kilter seems a little strange
at the end of the day he starts kind of
interrogating them right treating them
almost like people he doesn't trust
right he's like at least tell me how lex
luthor's involved with batman
incorporated why would you work for
someone like him is it the money and the
reality here is the reason why batman
incorporated was formed or at least the
reason why these individuals were chosen
is because money is not their god they
don't pursue money it's not the thing
they're looking for they're not
mercenaries they do what they do because
they legitimately believe that it's the
right thing to do and so because of that
they're just kind of like no you know
they almost kind of take offense to it
you know it was like lex luthor gave us
more than money he gave us a mission and
then when batman asked like what mission
was like you know lex luthor give you
they're like why do you care right like
we didn't need you before and we don't
need you now and they ultimately end up
attacking him right like batman has to
fight his own organization right batman
versus batman incorporated and it's cool
to see because he is able to overcome
them to a degree like the cop who's in
his earpiece talking to him is trying to
tell him what to do and he's like stop
right like you're a distraction you know
batman focusing on his sound or focusing
on his hearing is able to basically pick
up where each one of these guys are
coming from and is able to counter them
accordingly but just really kind of
lashes out here right like like talk to
me like why would you work with lex
luthor a batman that's that shady but
then suddenly the cops basically come
out of nowhere and then there's like
let's get to the roof right they
basically take off once they arrive up
on the rooftop of course him being
surrounded lex luthor arrives on the
scene and that's when of course we end
up finding one lex luthor survived and
two seemingly lex luthor's not blind at
the same time that happens you end up
having uh you end up having abyss who
arrives on the scene as well and
ultimately what lex luthor says here is
the only possible way for you to stop
abyss is to basically come with me right
like you have to work for me i can
provide you the tools the assets the
things that you need it's very very
cryptic and it's very weird because what
it looks like is lex luthor has
essentially set all this up and the
response of batman is like what games
are you playing right what did you do
how are you involved in this but
ultimately the members of batman
incorporated chime in and say like you
don't understand it batman like you
don't get what's going on lex luthor may
very well have funded our whole batman
incorporated situation here following
you losing all your money but abyss is
our leader and that's where abyss says
join us in the dark batman and help us
kill lex luthor right help us turn
against this guy and destroy him that's
their mission that's their secret
mission is to kill lex luthor and the
crazy thing about this is that as the
fight breaks out and is initially batman
begins to join lex luthor the two of
them fighting side by side against abyss
and batman incorporated you of course
end up finding out that this police
officer working alongside with batman is
calling back up and it's like the cops
are coming and all that kind of stuff
and ultimately abyss is like excellent
right like if you provided an audience
we can provide the show and he's like
batman incorporated prove your loyalty
kill lex luthor and so the fight breaks
out and it's pretty intense right this
is a pretty extreme fight and it's just
one of those things where literally lex
luthor points out that batman's blind
and everybody's like wait a minute what
like batman's blind right now like hold
on hold on like what in the hell like
lex luthor says okay like i prepared
myself for this fight batman says one of
the members of batman incorporated says
like look i'm sorry that it came down to
this batman and the response of bruce is
don't be and he says batman incorporated
code club of heroes and essentially
depending on how you feel about it it
was all an undercover operation
i feel like joshua williamson wrote
himself into a corner here that what's
basically going on or what basically
seemed to have been going on is that
batman incorporated have been working
with batman the entire time that the
reality is that they were all kind of
working together to basically bring out
abyss to trick abyss into believing that
he had the upper hand only to find out
that he didn't and ultimately the thing
about abyss is he's able to take them
out them all out essentially
single-handedly the other thing that
goes on here is that abyss says we all
want to be batman right no longer a
victim then lex luthor came to me with
an offer bruce wayne the tools to become
a new kind of batman and the training
but i was just the start of lex's
experiment he thought he could find
cities full of crime and create his own
batman one that was loyal to him but
then he abandoned me left me to show
this city how scary it can be in the
dark lex knew his little experiment got
away from him and sent a whole team of
batman to stop me that in essence lex
luthor was the one that caused all of
this that the way this timeline seems to
have played out is that with the absence
of of batman being able to fund batman
incorporated and knowing that the
loyalties of batman incorporated were
not to the highest bidder that what lex
luthor saw was an opportunity to
basically use experimentation right
probably gene modification or something
like that to basically create a new kind
of batman and then use this guy abyss as
what's basically a test subject for
reasons that aren't necessarily
explained here lex luthor abandoned the
whole idea of abyss now it may be one of
these things where this is all what
happened in the early days of batman
incorporated and that it doesn't really
seem to have been involved in anything
recent that lex luthor abandoning what
was going on with abyss and abandoning
creating his own batman in different
cities kind of his own version quote
unquote of batman incorporated that was
all abandoned because of the fact that
he basically turned over a new leaf and
that what abyss is experiencing here is
basically rejection right like he's
angry because he felt rejected by lex
luthor whatever the case happens to be
that ultimately lex essentially created
this whole thing and that the operation
was to basically find abyss bring him
out and then ultimately capture him now
one of the things here is that the the
nature of quote unquote this undercover
operation that while batman is the one
pulling the strings it didn't
necessarily seem to be something they
had worked out ahead of time what was
going on here is that batman
incorporated was basically being loyal
to to batman himself right and we'll
kind of talk about why here in a second
that they displayed this loyalty in a
way that batman would understand but
ultimately batman basically ends up
grabbing the suit of lex luthor because
that seems to be the thing that
protected him and kept him from going
blind indicating that the ability of
abyss to make batman go blind is
technologically based so ultimately
using the the technology in luther's
suit batman undoes his own blindness and
then in turn tracks down abyss and
literally just pummels him right like
using a combination of his own
technology to basically create what is
in effect a kind of white room a place
where abyss can't hide in the shadows
there's nowhere for him to go that is
about as a fair of a fight as it can
possibly be and batman overcomes him
swiftly right exceedingly fast like it's
just one of those things where abyss
never really had a chance in the first
place but ultimately when batman
overcomes him he essentially tells abyss
that he had lost sight of batman
incorporated right that lex luthor had
essentially prayed on that and he says i
didn't make you but i can still help you
and abyss says i only wanted to be like
you batman instead i'm always in the
dark and he says forever and he
ultimately ends up throwing down a kind
of bomb that just shrouds the entire
area and darkness and then ultimately
makes his escape and batman with no
choice ultimately ends up leaving and
going back to visit with the rest of
batman incorporated now this is where we
kind of get what was going on is a sense
that batman incorporated was always
loyal to batman there was never really
an instance when they had actually sided
with lex luthor if anything them siding
with lex luthor was them kind of
conducting their own investigation to a
degree to find out how lex luthor and
abyss were basically connected and that
once they were caught they ultimately
knew batman would catch up with him and
batman would continue the investigation
where they had essentially left off and
so when ultimately they're like i mean
like how did you know that we were
basically working with you right when
they kind of when they ultimately
abandoned lex and lex is back to doing
his own thing and doesn't really have
his own batman incorporated when they're
like how did you know that we were on
your side batman says because we were in
the prison you guys are all amazing
fighters it's one of the reasons why i
have you here is batman incorporated and
when you guys attacked me it was obvious
you were holding back you were pulling
your punches because you knew that abyss
was watching you like you knew that's
what was going on they were using just
essentially fighting styles and body
language to communicate with batman that
hey man we're on your side here you just
need to be aware of the fact that we're
doing this to essentially put on a show
now this is a very very important thing
because what it speaks to is one how
well batman and the other members of
batman incorporated know each other but
two the training that went into them
operating as a team that knows how to
communicate with batman because it's not
one of those things where like if they
knew abyss was watching they could like
punch him they could kick him and then
whisper stuff in his ear while they're
doing it like abyss is watching you know
and then like that kind of a thing they
they couldn't necessarily do that it had
to look real right because abyss is very
very capable and he would have picked up
on that almost instantaneously like he
would have realized okay they're
alerting batman to what's going on in
terms of all this stuff and so
ultimately when bruce asked them like
why didn't you call me for help right
why didn't you hit me up and let me know
what was going on their response is
would you have done the same thing right
communication is a two-way street home
slice would you have talked to us right
is that something that you would have
done and were you just kind of like i
probably wouldn't have and he's like
good job guys
i'll be in touch right i'm needed
elsewhere uh you guys continue on do
your thing great job uh awesome okay
cool peace and then like basically bales
basically takes off now we do get a
couple epilogues here one of them is
that he contacts ghost maker if you guys
recall him and says like i need you to
keep an eye on something for me but we
don't necessarily find out exactly
what's going on right there is the
batman annual for 2022 but that doesn't
go on sale until the end of may so we
won't know exactly what's going on until
then you do end up having this cop that
it basically investigates lex corp and
then kind of ask the question what lex
luthor was really up to the big takeaway
from all this is that prometheus is
basically speaking to an unnamed person
and saying our people have confirmed
that batman has returned to gotham city
and this unnamed person says make sure
my secret society monitors his movements
right this secret society of super
villains now prometheus himself is
basically a guy with the helmet he wears
it allows him to essentially analyze and
then understand the movements of people
he's fighting against so think of him
like a technological version of
taskmaster for those of you guys who are
coming from uh from marvel comics but
the person he's speaking to is basically
king deathstroke that deathstroke has
reformed the secret society of super
villains and that he intends to launch a
shadow war against batman which i'm
really excited to see what that looks
like but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace